brothers and sisters and dear friends
hope you guys are well inshallah uh
today I'm here for a specific reason I a
Muslim like you guys alhamd when it
comes to the issue of RBA this is
something that we are all afraid of it's
something that we all try to abstain
from and we don't need to go into the
details of the severity of the sin we
look for Solutions sometimes we can't
find Solutions um and there are people
who follow the F that you can buy a
first house on riba um but obviously
some of us hold the opinion that to be
better on the safe side alhamdulillah um
and sometimes Allah says in the Quran
inah Allah says in the Quran that if you
fear me I will give you a way out from
places you can never imagine so I
believe in this concept Allah subh will
always give us a way out and I am here
with two amazing Brothers may Allah
bless and preserve them uh they're
called fer usually I pronounce it as P
but we'll come to that in a minute so
we've got brother
resum do how are you alhamd BL you can
you guys introduce introduce yourself a
bit please yeah i' let R start yeah so
I'm R I'm the CEO and founder of fither
I founded fither back in
2016 uh by background I'm an acty which
is effectively a complex statistical
modeler I've worked in the London
financial markets all of my life uh for
the likes of PWC the bank of England L
of London Marketplace uh and I had a
life-changing experience on hudge in
2016 when I realized that with the skill
set that Allah has given me I have a
duty to try and do some good with that
skill set and try and create some
benefit for the umah so I gave up my
role at the bank of England as soon as I
came back from Hajj and I started
setting up father with a view to
providing a better way uh for providing
home ownership particularly for Muslims
that is completely free of debt and
completely free of
riba uh my name is Salman Hassan I'm the
chief legal officer and also head of
sharia at FAA I was about to say primary
finance that was our old name so my
background is I'm a Islamic Finance
lawyer I only ever practiced Islamic
Finance I worked at a International City
Law Firm both here and in Dubai worked
and advised all the big International
Banks across Europe and the Middle East
um but I was very disillusioned with
what's happening in the Islamic Finance
world because a lot of it is reversed
engineering they take non-islamic
interest bearing products and then quote
unquote islamized them they sort of
squeeze them into Islamic or Arabic
labeled contracts but really the
economic substance is exactly the same
and so I was very disillusioned by that
and I left my practice and started
looking for greater purpose something
could do to serve my community and then
razza came along and uh told me about
his journey and I joined his journey and
here we are today Mah amazing so you
guys want some f for the community I
mean is is is that what the does the
peace stand for people it does so I'm
just guessing of course I don't
know so yeah so the word father as many
people will recognize it means benefit
in many languages in fact so in Arabic
and in Turkish also in Udu and Bengali
many different languages and the p
actually stands for people as you say
because our intention is to always put
people first and bring great F to the
people may Allah bless you guys inah and
I went on your page cuz I I didn't know
about him as well and to me like is
someone that I know as well aldah um and
I thought to myself yeah I need to take
to see what he says and then I went on a
website I saw his picture and I was like
say no
more um okay so let's get straight into
it because TI for time in so tell us a
bit about how does your product work
yeah so to understand our product you
need to First understand the two
extremes of home ownership so on the one
extreme you've got a mortgage where you
borrow money from the bank you own the
property on day one and no matter what
happens to that property it's your
headache you still owe the hundreds of
thousands to the bank now that is a
straight up loan and any interest on
that loan is straight up River um the
opposite extreme is renting well you
don't own the property the landlord owns
the property now you don't take any of
the headache in the property in that
situation if the property is destroyed
with a mortgage you still owe the money
to the bank if the property is destroyed
or anything happens to it when you're
renting it's the landlord's headache you
can move on and move to another property
you don't have to worry about it our
product is somewhere in the middle is
the concept of owning part of the home
and renting part of the home so rather
than us lending money to the customer we
buy the property with the customer as
partners the customer can rent our share
and that is the only obligation so the
way to think of it is imagine you're
renting from a landlord you can your
only obligation to your landlord is to
pay your rent on time every month and
take reasonable care over the property
you can go to your landlord anytime and
say I'd like to buy your property from
you and the landlord may say yep sure
you you can buy it from me that's
absolutely fine but you don't have to
it's up to you if you want to and that's
the same with our product so maybe you
own 20% or 50% up front we put in the
remainder you just have to pay rent on
the part of the property that isn't
yours and if you want at any time you
can buy us out as well you can offer to
buy shares at any um speed you like or
not at all you can just rent for the
rest of your life if you like it's
entirely up to you so it's a very very
flexible approach it's based on genuine
partnership which means we share in the
risks of partnership so the assd test is
what happens if the property is
destroyed in a mortgage you owe that
money to the bank even in is Islamic
Bank mortgage you must immediately buy
the bank's share off of them for the
asset which no longer exists whereas in
our partnership we take the risk
together if the property is destroyed
you take the loss on your share we take
the loss on our share and that is what
defines a true partnership okay that's
brilliant um I'm going to come to more
questions a bit later on that there's
another product that you offer which is
the savings accounts yes just just touch
up on that please yes so we offer
savings accounts as well effectively
when you put money in a bank that money
in a conventional Bank um is used to
lend with interest so many people don't
realize this when you put £100 in your
bank account you're actually agreeing to
let the bank use your money to lend with
interest and as Muslims that should make
us extremely uncomfortable um even
Islamic Banks when you put money in an
Islamic Bank um all banks all all
regulated Banks this is how the banking
system works they use that money to
print new money and the act of printing
new money devalues the very money you're
putting into the bank and the people who
suffer the most from that are the poor
so the banking system is actually
designed to make the rich richer and the
poor poorer so the way our savings
accounts work there's no money creation
there's no rii Lending
we use that money specifically to put
people into homes in a debt-free riba
free mechanism and you get a Halal
return on that in the form of a share of
the income that we're receiving on those
homes so it's a very very Halal savings
account you know exactly what your money
is being used for and it's uh by virtue
of the fact we're not printing new money
it's uh not contributing to the widening
of the rich Pro divide the other thing
to think about is when you put your
money in a bank account because that
money is devaluing your money it makes
it harder for you to buy a house because
it actually it's a Perpetual cycle it's
a Perpetual cycle so actually the very
worst thing we can do is leave all of
our money in a bank account yes Banks
serve a purpose we need our everyday
cards to spend on every day and draw
cash from the machine every day but
leaving all of our savings in a bank
account that is what's promoting the um
inflationary cycle which is making
houses more and more AFF unaffordable
and actually we as Muslims need to do
better we need to be putting our money
in places which don't price us out of
our own homes and which we know is only
being used for Halal and promoting
wealth particular amongst Muslims okay
so personally for myself if I have a
certain amount of money in my account um
instead of it sitting there and the bank
using it as riba which I do not want to
but it's CU I have no other choice um if
I put it here the only catch with you
guys is that um you can't deposit it
it's an investment so it's a saving
account but it's not your typical so
when you put it there you get a a a
return on it it's an investment because
you're using it to invest in properties
correct ex which is your other product
which if there's homeowners you want to
buy a house so if you have money which
you guys are if there's anyone watching
like okay I have this much money and I'm
going to it's going to be sitting in my
account for the one two years instead of
it being used for riba put it here where
it's you get it's an investment yeah so
so generally speaking the worst thing
you can do is leave all of your money
sitting idle yeah as Muslims what we
need to do as a community is we need to
skill up and we need to get used to and
comfortable with the concept of
investing it's also equally not sensible
to invest all of your money in one place
so I'm not saying people should take all
of their money and put it with f but
there should be an allocation uh for
something like this which is a lowrisk
alternative to a bank account there
should also be an allocation and we
should get more comfortable with this to
highrisk Investments maybe it shouldn't
be a very large allocation but as you
get more and more comfortable with
investing this is what we as a community
need to get better at the worst thing
we're doing as a community is hoarding
all of our wealth in one place in a bank
account where we don't benefit from that
money um the poor don't benefit from
that money the only people who benefit
from that money are the wealthy Bankers
who are already wealthy enough we need
to do far far better as Muslims and
that's why we've created our F savings
account to provide one alternative to
that okay that's well and good
alhamdulillah and uh your name is very
unique uh but the people are going to
ask a question what is unique about your
like what about other products for
example how is it different to other
products yeah so uh let's compare to a
conventional mortgage and also to an
Islamic Bank mortgage and also to other
shared ownership products so in a
conventional mortgage as I mentioned
it's a debt you're borrowing money from
the bank you have to pay that back with
interest and most Shier Scholars will
agree that's not permissible there is
the exception where some Scholars allow
you to buy one house on a mortgage if we
take an Islamic Bank mortgage the way it
works is rather than the bank lending
you money the bank buys the property and
you must now B buy the bank's share out
of them over a set period of time for a
set price no matter what happens to the
property and this has Sharia uh gray
areas in it and it does definitely
create uh a divide in some Muslims are
happy with it some Scholars are happy
with it and some are very very against
it alhad who has approved our product is
one of those Scholars who does not agree
with that approach and shean will talk
to that a bit
more um the next product is a shared
ownership product which is actually the
closest to our product but most shared
ownership products what they do is they
say right you own part of the property
you rent our share and you can buy a out
over time which is exactly how our
product works but the difference is most
shared ownership products will say um
when you want to buy our shares from us
we will revalue the property and you
will buy them from us at the current
market value now we know in the UK
property prices tend to increase 5 to
10% per anom year on year wages only
tend to increase 1 to 2% perom year on
year what this means is the property
becomes more and more affordable over
time because wages don't keep up with
property prices now what this means is
most people on shared ownership schemes
will never be able to fully own their
house rigged system in a sense where
because it's like you're just in again
in a Perpetual cycle like a rent trap
yeah it's like a ren sh because as it's
increasing you're not buying nothing you
might be stuck on 50% for the next 10
years because of the way yeah it can the
longer you wait to buy out the property
the more difficult it becomes and that's
the problem with most shared ownerships
are you telling me that F sticks to the
price that was agreed correct so what
what we you know why would you do that
people would say why would you do such a
thing well the question is why why did I
leave my very lucrative City Job to set
this up when I could make much more
money doing what I was doing and it's
because I feel I have a responsibility
as I said I had a life-changing
experience on hjj and I know she Salman
has the exact same vision um so I set up
father to with a vision and A View to
try and increase wealth particularly
amongst Muslims and increase home
ownership particularly amongst Muslims
because you do not need to be poor to be
financially excluded Muslims are
financially excluded from investment
products and finance products just due
to their faith and due to the fact that
riba is not permitted so we decided
actually the only way to enact that
vision is to uh sell the property to
customers at the original cost to make
it affordable and we created our
business model around the rental income
we receive so that's how we make our
money from the rental income we decided
that we won't take the upside on the
property value with some exceptions so
when the customer is buying the property
from us we sell it at the original cost
to make it affordable however if the
customer wants to sell the property now
they're actually making a profit on the
sale of the property and as partners we
have taken risk in the property we are
genuine Partners it's fair in that
situation that we take our share of
profit as well but as long as the
customer is buying it from us to make it
affordable we sell it at the original
cost and that's our way of enacting this
Vision okay that's brilliant I'm going
to go to before I do that because even
when I'm given da I try to stick to
simple terminologies yeah I don't get
the whole yeah I just keep it very
simple people understand so the the
agreement between let's say for example
there's £100,000 house argument sake I
bring £50,000 insh I have that money one
day and I give 50,000 you guys put
50,000 we have a house so the hle is we
are going to rent it so let's say the
rent of that house is
£1,000 um because I own 50% of that um
and you own 50% F when we rent it you
take the rent from you ask me should we
rent it out would you like to rent it
yourself I say let's rent it out so we
rent it out I take 500 you take 5500
every month so so the way it works is um
let's say you're living in the property
let's say I'm not okay so you want to
rent the property yes so what we'll do
is we we'll say look our contract is for
you to rent the property from us now how
you pay us your rent is up to you you
can have your own tenant if you want you
can rent it out to somebody else and you
can pay us from the rent you make from
your tenant it's entirely up to you okay
and that means you can rent the property
out if you want to or you can live in it
and you can pay the rent yourself
the usle is not that you rent it out the
usle is that I rent it out or I rent it
myself sorry I thought was the other one
okay so meaning that I can choose to say
I'm going to rent it out to David and
David pays rent I'll give you 50% share
do I give it or are you guys managing
that no so so the idea is we don't want
to be involved in your business okay so
you have complete discretion over who
you want to rent it out to and that's
why we say look on the 50% of the
property so normally the property rents
for £1,000 on 50% it's £500 so you just
pay us the £500 rent every month you can
rent it to David for £5,000 it doesn't
matter you just have to give us 500
which is for sh the value of the rent of
the area exct so if I say you know
actually no I want to live in it
therefore what I do is I owe you that
£500 CU I already already own the 50% of
the correct simple exactly let's go to
the Shar side with Dr s BL you uh so
what is your approach to the Sharia
compliance when it comes to yeah so and
as I said in the introduction I was very
disillusioned with the approach taken by
Islamic Banks and and in the law firm I
was as a lawyer able to pop the Bonnet
of all of these contracts and look
underneath most people don't have the
ability to do that and I I could see
what they were doing was reverse
engineering they were taking interest
bearing contracts and doing exactly the
same thing but just doing it through a
different contractual structure if you
like we call that reverse Financial
engineering and that that's not the
approach we take so we take a purist
approach and that goes to not just the
letter of the sh but also the spirit of
the Shar so what is what is Allah's we
call it in Arabic what is the or the
wisdom behind why Allah has prohibited
riba because if Allah's prohibited riba
it's it's not just because it's
prohibited it's because it has a harmful
effect on society and us and everything
right but if we're replicating that
harmful effect by quote unquote applying
Sharia contracts but doing exactly the
same thing the economic effect on
society is going to be exactly the same
and so not only does it have the same
harmful effect it has the the the the
facad or the ma that non-muslims will
look at Islamic finance and they do I've
been in embarrassing situations with
non-muslim lawyers who look at Islamic
Finance contracts Islamic Banking and
say well you're just doing the same
thing how is that Islamic EXA and it's
embarrassing because this is supposed to
be a dawa we're supposed to show society
and the world that Islam has a solution
to a corrupt Financial system but if
actually we're replicating that the
corrupt outcome of that Financial system
through the quote unquote Islamic
Financial system system we're not only
doing disservice to the community and
Society we're doing a disservice to
Islam this is this is harmful for da and
so so I and having studied Sharia
because I studied Sharia out in the
Middle East in in Syria back in the
early
2000s I I dedicated my life to trying to
live that sh and apply it but practicing
as an Islamic Finance lawyer I was kind
of doing the opposite and so our
approach and and this is Testament to
alhamd our purist approach when we first
went toam and presented our product to
him he asked us one question and he said
do you force your customer to buy your
share of the property so you bought it
together as you in the example you gave
he said do you forc your customer to buy
a share cuz that's what puts the
customer into debt because if if we've
effectively sold our share to the
customer exactly yeah and so look at the
end of in layman's terms let's put it in
layman's terms if I put somebody into
debt regardless of how I put them into
debt I could put them into debt by
giving them a loan yes I give you1 you
owe me £1 that's a simple loan right or
I could put you into debt by saying
let's enter into a a CO the ship on the
house it's £100,000 house you put in
50,000 we put in 50,000 but immediately
in the same contract we force you to buy
our share for exactly 50,000 right so
can you see the co ownership doesn't
exist anymore we've sold our share and
you're going to pay us installments over
20 or 30 years right so now all the
liability is passed on to you you owe me
the Islamic Bank a money debt right you
see so we've created a debt in a
roundabout way now if I charge you more
on top of that debt what have I done
what is charging more on top of a debt
isn't that the basic definition of R
exactly yeah so so that's the approach
we take we take a really purest approach
and we don't do that they're not they're
not giving any fighter to the people are
they well if you're putting people into
debt then you've got the same negative
effects of debt on society exactly and
we want fight for the
people so okay so next question she is
um what makes F home finance product
Shia compliant yeah so this is this is I
mean I kind of already explained it so
what we do is we enter into this Co
ownership so simple example we put in
future, you put in future thousand now
at this point we're we're Partners in
the property right the Sharia requires
that we have to share the risk and the
reward of that partnership that's what
happens if I sell you my share
immediately I'm I'm not sharing that
risk or reward I'm just simply putting
all that risk onto you that's the first
thing right so now we've said that with
Islamic Banks they sell you their share
and then they charge you rent on that
share rent on top of that debt and
that's not allowed what we do is we say
you don't have to buy our share if you
don't want to if you want to you can and
our policy is always to sell our share
to you at the original acquisition cost
why because of that that F because we
want the we want we want to facilitate
affordable home ownership for the
community we don't want to put them into
a debt trap or a rent trap and we've
created that middle path yeah so you now
have the option but not the obligation
to buy our share of us but until you've
done that what your obligation is
because you're living in that property
or you've taken responsibility for that
property to rent out to another person
you've taken a lease out on that prop or
our share you will then pay us rent
that's your only Shar obligation on a
month-to-month basis okay brilliant so
the well the third question I think you
already answered it what's wrong with
Islamic banking yeah we've kind of
explained it explained it yeah so um
what makes figh investment saving
account Sharia compliance so that's your
other product that you guys yes yeah how
do it show so what we do is we've got
this really beautiful system we've
effectively created what I would call a
a sort of housing Cooperative or a
housing committee right you know in the
commune we have people who club together
and they have these credit committees
yeah we've kind of RI that large and we
have a housing committee where instead
of people putting their money in the
bank and what the bank does is use it
for Haram reasons what the bank does is
actually lends our money back to us and
charges us more for it the bank is
effectively a middleman right and then
that's how they fleece money of society
they they they take our money and they
put us into debt with our own money
right what we've done is we've we've
effectively opted out of that system we
say right if the Muslim Community put if
we put our money into Islamic financial
institutions that are genuine and purely
based on Sharia then we can aggregate
our own capital and we can help each
other buy our own homes and cut out the
bank
the debt BAS system do you see so that's
effectively what we done so when people
open up an investment savings account
with us they um we we take that money we
use that money to finance the homes of
the people who are our customers and
then from that rental income we take a
share for managing the scheme and we
give a share to our investors so what
our investors are getting is a share of
the rental income from a property
portfolio interesting okay that's
interest so what what do they get yearly
like percentage um it depend yeah I let
rather it depend on on which account
yeah so just to answer that very quickly
we have different savings accounts and
they uh we've got one savings account
aimed at people looking to buy a home
with us we have another savings account
aimed at people who aren't looking to
buy a home they just want to put their
money and get the best return possible
at the time of recording uh that account
pays up to
4.7% and that's paid in the form of
dividends which have their own tax-free
allowance in the UK so generally unless
someone is using their dividend
allowance elsewhere they can invest up
to £20,000 with us completely taxfree
right uh and also uh it's also worth
mentioning the zakat treatment here and
maybe she you can talk about the zakat
treatment on the investment as well yeah
so firstly we don't advise uh our
customers on on on their zakat treatment
because as you know there are different
schools of of opinion within Islam on on
the treatment of zakat so we ask people
to get their own sort of views from
their from the mhab or the IM that they
follow but what we do is we we do
provide information on what the possible
zakat treatments could be now there is a
strong body of opinion within Islamic
law that if you buy a property and you
rent that property out you activate that
property for for a useful economic
purpose you've given somebody else a
home they're giving you a rental income
there's an economic purpose there and
and and the Sharia in that in that in
that view says that zakat is not due on
the capital amount of that property yeah
because if you think about it if I buy a
property I've got £100,000 savings I buy
property with that and I rent that out
if I then next year have to pay 2 and a
half% of that property I might not have
that might have to sell the property
which is giving me an income and giving
somebody a home in order to pay the
zakat so the Sharia doesn't want to sort
of put somebody out of their home and
put me out of my income you see so what
the Shar say is you pay zakat on the
rental income of that property not on
the price that you bought the property
with right now if you think about it
when when people open up an investment
savings account with us their money goes
into buying properties which are rented
out to our customers you see so the
zakat treatment of that whole portfolio
of those investment saving accounts is
that according to this view which is one
of the which is a sort of a view within
the Shar that zakat is not due now of
course we have many of our customers who
say I just pay the zakat anyway okay
yeah so what we do is on a on a when the
zakat date comes and they they input the
zakat date on the app that they have
with us we send them a notification that
this is how much you you can factor in
into your own balance sheet in order to
calculate your zakat and some people pay
it and some people don't it's totally up
to them so if they don't so you said did
you say 4.7% or okay so is that
including the 2 and a half% of the zaka
that they don't need to pay in that 4.57
4.7% or is it so so that's that's the
return that you can expect to get to
your bank account now if you follow the
majority opinion there will be no Z cut
to pay on that but some some people take
a more conservative opinion and they pay
the cut anyway so for the so for the
ones that don't do you add that 2.5%
into the 4 point no so so the 4.7 is the
return you get to your bank account if
you if you imagine comparing to a bank
account imagine on uh you've got your
money in a b bank account and the bank
is paying you 4.7% interest right your
savings in the bank account let's say
you've got 100,000 you're very wealth
you've got 100,000 in your bank account
um you will have to pay zart on that
full 100,000 every single year because
you are leaving your money idle and not
activating your wealth and this is
Allah's way of telling us if you can't
find anything useful to do with your
wealth at least give 2 and a half% to
the poor from it right so with our
savings account if you put the same
100,000 into our savings account as long
as you the majority opinion you don't
have to pay 2 and a half% on that
anymore because your money is going
directly into property which is being
rented out to customers okay so the 4.7%
you're given you get to keep all of it
you get to keep all of it and then you
got the 2.5% that you don't have to pay
in zaka correct so in in equivalence if
you if to to to get the same return on a
bank account or even an Islamic Bank
account because bank accounts are also
effectively a debt based contract You'
need to in you need you need a 2 5%
higher return to get the same real rate
of return yeah so so you in in another
bank account if you earning
7.3% right you would then net 2 and a
half% off of that for zakat and you
wouldd end up with 4.7% whereas with us
you get the 4.7% and you don't have to
net any zard off exactly so you're left
with what whatever you take you get to
keep you don't have to pay anything else
on top of it so it's an extra 2.5% if
you think about it it's com to 7 and you
can understand the wisdom
um of you know we call this the of of
because some people ask why is zakat not
do on this shouldn't we pay zakat and it
goes to the poor it's a good thing and
it's really important that we encourage
it's a pillar of Islam you know we
encourage the payment of zakat and
people who aren't paying zakat we
encourage them to pay zakat but you know
there's wisdom in everything that Allah
gives us we don't make these rules up
Allah has given us these rules and you
know we've come across scenarios where
suppose somebody is on a middle income
or lower than average income and they're
really struggling to to save up for a
home and they're in a council property
or they're in temporary accommodation or
they're renting and the landlord keeps
throwing them out every year and their
children have to change school and it
creates trauma and their wife can't
settle down and there's damp and you
know there isn't dignity in that
person's life and that person's
struggling to raise a deposit to buy a
home on the say an Islamic Finance or
Islamic Bank morage or with us right now
if they're saving up if every year they
have to pay 2 and a half% every 4 years
they're losing 10% of that deposit right
now that person isn't in peny they're
not eligible to receive zaka they're not
sort of in in in in poverty but that
person's really struggling you see and
so sometimes you can see the hikma the
wisdom behind Allah's laws in situations
like this where Allah is saying well
actually if you can activate your money
into purposeful economic activity give
somebody else a home while you wait uh
get a bit of return while you wait and
increase your your your your your
deposit then you know you don't have to
pay zakat on that and then Allah is
helping that person raise a deposit to
get into helping on a micro level yeah
exactly yeah yeah okay so uh what
petition does the customers have yeah so
the way we've uh structured this the
customer has what we call an equity
buffer and they have a lot of
flexibility in their payment so I'll go
through that let's consider a
conventional mortgage or even an Islamic
Bank mortgage where your monthly payment
is let's say £1,000 which is your
interest plus your Capital repayment or
within Islamic Bank your rent plus your
Equity purchase both of those elements
are obligatory in both of those
situations so in a month your car breaks
down you have to pay the mechanic you've
only got £800 in your pocket you can't
meet the
,000 what that means is you're in
default and the bank is maybe going to
give you two months payment holiday to
make good on that default a conventional
bank will charge you interest on that as
well in the middle and if you can't make
good on that shortfall the bank is going
to take your house away from you with
our product the rental element is
obligatory alhamdulillah the equity
purchase is not so your target monthly
payment May still be £1,000 which is
your rent plus your target level of
equity purchase to get to full home
ownership but that bit is optional so in
a month maybe of that, let's say 600 is
rent and 400 is equity purchase in a
month you've only got 800 in your pocket
you can choose to pay your 600 rent and
only purchase 200 of equity that month
so it gives you enormous Breathing Room
in times of difficulty and you can
manage this all through our app you can
go into our app anytime and change your
payments according to your needs we give
enormous flexibility to the customer um
let's say the customer loses their job
and can't even afford to pay their £600
rent well with our structure every time
you purchase Equity you get actual share
certificates tangible proof of your
ownership and so uh what you can do is
fall back on what we call your Equity
buffer in times of difficulty if you
can't pay us in cash you can pay us from
your Equity buffer instead and to put
this into perspective an average
customer who has 10% initial Equity
deposit if you like if they lose their
job on day one without ever having made
a payment that 10% Equity buffer will
last the average customer 2 to 4 years
so that's a huge amount of security so
that if the worst case happens you lose
your job you're down on your knes the
last thing you have to think is how am I
going to pay the bank right you know
you've got security of the roof over
your head so you can focus on what's
important getting back on your feet
finding another job and starting to make
payments again because we think it's
reprehensible that when a customer is
down on their knees going through the
hardest time of their life the bank then
comes and kicks them out of their house
we personally think that should be
illegal and actually the you know the
etiquette of Islam teaches us when your
customers facing difficulties you grant
them ease rather than further hardship
and that's the approach we take at F
okay Mar amazing um so are you are you
guys regulated by the FCA and if not why
not yeah really good question so it's
important to note that we went through
the full regulatory process with the FCA
we went through a full two-year process
the FCA reviewed every single part of
our product and they themselves
concluded it doesn't fall within the
regulatory remit the reason for this is
if you look at conventional mortgages a
conventional mortgage is a lifelong debt
and many of your listeners uh may not be
aware the word mortgage actually means
death grip it comes from French and many
of you recognize the word Mort which
means death so the word mortgage means
death grip because you are effectively
in this grip for the rest of your life
so you have a lifelong debt to the bank
if that product is the wrong product for
you it's going to ruin your life without
a doubt that's why it has to be very
heavily regulated now take the opposite
extreme when you're renting from a
landlord if you're renting from a
landlord and it's the wrong property for
you it won't ruin your life you can
simply move on to another property I'm
not saying it's easy but it's definitely
not going to ruin your life in the same
way a lifelong debt will and that's why
landlords do not need to be regulated by
the FCA because there's much less risk
to the consumer our product as I
explained earlier is effectively a
landlord tenant product You're simply
renting you have no debt and because
there is no debt it's not going to ruin
your life you can stop change move on
anytime you like so the FCA themselves
concluded actually this does not need to
be regulated and actually after year one
they came to that conclusion and funny
story we went to them and said why don't
you regulate us anyway because it will
give confidence to our customers so we
went through another whole one-year
process with them and they concluded
look we're not set up to regulate
entities that don't need to be regulated
just like if a landlord went to the FCA
and said why don't you regulate me the
FCA would say no you're a land you don't
need to be regulated and we are in the
same situation so uh what if um f goes
boss yeah really good question so uh you
can think of f like the landlord right
if if f as an entity were to go bust
actually from the customers perspective
there's no one to collect their rent
anymore so funnily enough it just means
they've got no one collecting their rent
anymore but the the house is still
theirs they still have a lease they
still have the right to live in the
property just means there's no to
collect their rent but uh we've actually
structured it uh very specifically to
protect customers in that situation so
all of the houses are owned by a
separate entity rather than being owned
by F that separate entity is when you
open a savings account with us you get
shares in that entity when you're a
customer your shares transform into your
partnership rights over the property and
that means this entity that owns the
properties is not owned by F fither just
has a one penny share in it which allows
us to manage it but it's actually owned
by our customers and our savings account
holders which means think of think of a
very simple case where you own a company
and you have an accountant managing your
company for you if anything happens to
your accountant you still own that
company you still own those assets you
don't make any loss you can find another
accountant to manage your company for
you and this is exactly how our
structure works f is really like an
accountant managing the company on
behalf of our customers and Savers but
if anything was to happen to us we're no
different to an accountant managing your
company it's still still your company it
still belongs to you okay so does that
answer the question of what is the
likelihood of the funding vehicle goes
going bus right no that's a separate
question so the The Entity that owns all
of the underlying properties yes account
yeah then yeah yeah so so what causes
companies to go bust it's really debt
when the company cannot pay the money
that it own that it owes to its
creditors right now this funding vehicle
um first of all it's important to
clarify all of F's expenses are covered
by f itself okay so this funding vehicle
isn't responsible for those expenses by
there's a separate company that covers
its own expenses the only expenses in
this funding vehicle there is no by the
way there is no debt in any part of our
structure not at the F level not at the
funding vehicle level so debt is the
number one thing that causes companies
to go bust and there's no debt anywhere
in our structure alhamdulillah so at the
funding vehicle level the only expenses
are actually bank account charges which
are very very minimal and once a year we
get that and audited uh because again
it's good good practice to have an
independent accountant audit that
company and make sure it's running
smoothly and make sure the numbers are
all stacking up and that gives
confidence to our investors and
customers as well but those are
basically the only expenses of that
company and as a result it's what uh you
would call bankruptcy remote because it
has very very few creditors so the
likelihood of that uh we would hope
would be extremely remote repeat that
again the last bit um the risk of so so
um the the number one thing which causes
companies to go bus is debt and not
being able to pay its creditors now in
this instance the funding company has no
debt okay which is the biggest reason
for companies going bus and its
creditors are very very few it's the
bank account charges and once a year the
auditor fees in the worst case scenario
the auditor fee is you know something
which in that scenario wouldn't have to
be paid right that's something we elect
to do yearly right uh and the bank
account charges are very very minimal so
it has very very few creditors and
therefore it should be very very
bankruptcy remote okay so uh before we
go to how people can apply um so if if
somebody buys a share of the house um I
heard I don't correct me that they not
actually buying the share of the house
by the share of the company is this true
or is there a is there a clear contract
that shows that this individual who buys
50% of the house owns 50% of the house
yeah yeah so the way the way it works is
imagine you let's take a simple example
you could buy a house and you could buy
it directly and have it in your name or
you could set up a company and then have
the company buy the house so you fully
own the company and then the company
buys the house so you own the house but
indirectly through the company right now
let's let's now take it take it as
though you're buying the house in shares
with us so we set up a company together
and you put in 50,000 we put in 50,000
to the company and then the company owns
that property right but because you have
a share in the company and we have a
share in the company we are effectively
co-owners of that property now if you
scale that up and you say right let's
have one company which will own all of
the properties for all
you see okay so so so basically even
though it it seems like you're investing
in the shares of the company it's
actually owning their specific property
that's right and then they are uh buying
out the shares of let's say individuals
in the savings accounts money who's been
used to buy that house they are sely
buying those shares out yeah so the way
the way the deed works is it says if
it's £100,000 property
and you've got £50,000 of shares your
partnership rights are 50% that means uh
your rent is reduced by 50% because
you're not paying rent on the share that
you owe it means if the property is sold
you have a right to 50% of the proceeds
so it dictates your partnership rights
based on how many shares you have in the
company and actually just by having
shares in the company you are one of the
ultimate beneficial owners of that
property anyway because you are one of
the owners of the company that owns the
property yes but specifically my cut of
the share would be made clear corre on
that specific property and then you
might have thousands of other people who
uh okay and so so simple example with
the £100,000 house once your shares in
the company reach £100,000 at that point
we would transfer the property to you
and then that's the end of the contract
okay interesting so then people are
going to ask is uh for those who are
happy with the answers how do they
apply yeah so it's important to mention
here that we do have a waiting list
um and as you can imagine this is a
radically refreshingly different product
so we've got a huge huge amount of
demand alhamdulillah so uh anybody can
sign up to the waiting list by just
going on to the website and signing up
but the waiting list is quite long we do
have um a shortcut and basically anybody
who opens a savings account with us
specifically a home savings account so a
savings account for people looking to
buy homes um they're feeding into the
system and they're supporting this giant
committee structure that Salan talked
about and so we reward them by serving
them quicker so if you're if you just
want to get on the waiting list that's
fine but if you support the system and
put your deposit in sooner and allow
your deposit being to be used to help
others while you wait then what we do is
we promote you onto what we call a
priority waiting list and we serve you
quicker and there's full details of that
on our website and shelle and then when
your turn comes we reach out to you and
say okay your turn is here now it's time
for you to start looking for a house and
then we take you through that whole
journey okay interesting I mean I don't
really have any other questions to ask
um personally like I'm personally um
satisfied um and obviously with this
stuff because as public figures we're
very careful who we uh associate with
who we work with in the when it comes to
other dies Etc uh because at the end of
the day not that we're anything special
about it's just affiliation so when it
comes to this when it comes to people's
money as well um like I said before you
know Dr Allah bless him yourself being
behind this um I've ask a relevant
questions
I don't see any you know I would say
I've I believe believe that I've tied my
camel to a certain extent said to the
man who was going to I think to the m I
can't remember and he he left his camel
untied and he said I put my trust in
Allah well interesting thing in those
times the people had more than doing
their work today we have um people who
are not just tying the camel their camel
is dead because they're too focused on
thinking it's in their hands and the
camel has sadly died and they have no
sadly so I believe I've tied my camel I
will be doing
and after if this video goes public that
means I trust it you know alhamdulillah
I've spoken to you guys and we assume
the best of the Believers may Allah
bless you guys and preserve you guys for
trying to benefit the the um I do see
that in you guys and yeah may Allah
bless you guys and guys if you're
watching it and you are convinced by it
I mean um you can ask further questions
you can get in contact with them we'll
put all the contact details at the
description box below um and yeah come
here ask more questions if you would
like to inallah uh that's those are the
main questions I have asked and yeah
that's all all I have to say brother
sisters um and yeah uh check it out and
maybe you can buy first house with them
or if you have some kind of money
sitting around you can invest in the
savings account um and let that inshah
benefit you and your family uh till next
time